breakfast seven lunch noon dinner 7 30.
and how many guests are there
nine total
hello everybody
welcome
namaste
nine perfect strangers bringing a big
eclectic group of actors together to
star in this was really exciting in 10
days
you will leave tranquil house and you
will feel happier healthier
freer the story is about these nine
people who all arrive at tranquillium a
wellness retreat this has happened your
wellness journey has begun francis
tranquilm is a place where people come
to seek a sense of enlightenment i feel
like they belong perhaps okay you
feeling as well as you've ever felt
francis welty is a very successful
romance novelist but for the first time
in her life she's had a career blip and
that's a big blow to her you're sick i
beg your pardon you seem to be having
some kind of a mental
breakdown sort of thing i'm not judging
i play a guy named tony hogburn and
tony's an ex-nfl player has a painkiller
addiction he doesn't have a relationship
with his family and he's sort of at the
end of his rope
he's no problem man just needs to nudge
it up a little so i could pull in
ben him and jessica they won the lottery
for 50 million dollars so at first their
life was a simple life but they were
happy but more money more problems they
kind of lost a passion for life why
doesn't he love you anymore
i do
jessica
has undiagnosed body dysmorphic disorder
so she's augmented her body a lot
paralyzing
anxiety it's made a marriage very
stressful sides are too big and the
stomach isn't flat enough do you really
not think that you're pretty i just want
to go
pow
carmel she is divorced her husband has
fallen in love with someone else so
she's certainly a woman who is is
dealing with a lot of pain we were in
love
you can trust me she's searching for who
she is i think she's she's doing a bit
of soul-searching carmel you terrify me
what last he's somebody that keeps his
emotions quite in check people don't
really know anything about him he is an
undercover reporter he's there to dig
out the truth but he starts to deal with
his own things that he has suppressed
which is not something he's used to
biggest threat to the planet is
overpopulation and these bloody breeders
keep pumping them up it's incredible
you're still single
zoe
her and her family her mom her dad comes
to tranquillum completely broken because
her twin brother dies by suicide she's
okay no she's she's not okay none of us
are okay heather is stuck because she
lost her child coming to tranquillium is
a last-ditch effort to
involve herself in her daughter zoe and
her husband napoleon
[Music]
just write it elsewhere
i was so thrilled to work with michael
shannon i'm terrified that's part of it
isn't it you do something that scares
you
every single character has this deep
secret that they're trying to hold on to
to cover up and i think you get to see
what happens to people when a light is
shining or in their darkness i'm not
sure i'm really supposed to be here it's
so easy for me to believe that all of
these people no matter where they were
from would seek tranquillium
it's going to have more twists and turns
and every range of emotion we need to
get out of here
having all of these extraordinary actors
we've managed to bring all of these
people together and i think that's
really exciting
just be happy
we're gonna get you well
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you